Today, I learned that vitamins were discovered
by the butter industry. It's like 1913,
and the margarine industry is threatening to
compete with butter. Margarine being a fat
substitute that's not made from dairy. Anyway. So
these massive dairy industries like in Wisconsin,
are like, “No way, Jose. Butter is better
than margarine. We got to prove it.” So
they do what corporations have always done
and continue to do, which is hire scientists
to prove that their product is actually really
good. And soon they're showing that the rats
that ate butter were like better than the
ones that ate margarine And they were like,
“Oh, this is like a good marketing thing. But
like, why are the butter-fed rats fatter and
happier and healthier?” And in doing all their
experiments, they isolated this micronutrient,
this molecule that our bodies need. They called it
a vitamin. And because the one that they found in
butter was like the first one they discovered,
they're like, “what should we call it?” “A,
like first letter of the alphabet, Vitamin A.”
That's how we got vitamin A. Since then, we've
discovered 13 essential vitamins. So you can thank
butter for vitamins. Thank you, butter. Love you.